A day in a Turkish family always starts with a strong breakfast...
...of varied but simple produce.
Being an agricultural land, most of the people will have a really heavy meal just after dawn...
...and have something like a soup or bread traditionally.
But in the last 100 years, with the amount of produce that is coming out of Turkey,...
...it became a lot more rare item:...
...different types of cheeses, fresh fruit in season,...
...jams, pastries, vegetables and all-day with the Turkish tea as well.
Van is a city in East Anatolia and famous for its breakfast...
...defined by the variety of boutique cheeses produced around the region.
Some are barrel-aged feta, fresh goat cheeses mixed with native herbs...
...or another example of our fascination with stuffing food is tulum cheese:...
...sheep cheese stuffed and preserved in goat skin.
An abundance of Mediterranean fruits in the region is reflected on the breakfast table.
Grapes, cherries, strawberries, watermelon and stone fruits...
...are generally picked fresh from the garden or the market.